every time there is one of these
problems with reporting at a major news
organization and sadly this is not
unique Brian Williams is not unique he's
not close to unique he's not even unique
over the last 10 years and you can go
back not too far and see the New York
Times and The Associated Press and CBS
News you can see so many instances of
this every time this happens it takes
away a little the credibility of
everybody in the news business one of
the mistakes some people make is they
think oh you know that's bad for them
but it's good for us I never believed
that I always believed that most people
sadly will say oh that's probably what
they all do and so I think it takes
something away from all the news
organizations and the hard part is the
only way to gain it back is over a long
period of time proving day in and day
out that you're getting it right you
could have one big incident take down
your credibility there's no one big
incident that will bring it back up it
takes years to overcome that perception
but I think it's bad for all of em when
something like this happens there's no
room I don't think for gloating at all
it's mistake
you